hi everyone it's great to see you here
hope you had a great lunch my name is
Ben gable I'm a game developer and
developer advocate here at Google I work
with game developers to help them make
great games on Android and today I'm
here to talk to you all about a topic
that I find very personally interesting
and that is adapting android games
beyond the phone so it wasn't too many
years ago that when somebody said mobile
gaming or Android gaming you think of a
device like this right and there's
everybody knows what this is right it's
a phone so you've got a touchscreen
you've got an accelerometer gyro
controls resolution and aspect ratio are
pretty standard across all of them but
I'm here today to tell you guys that
Android gaming is not just phones
anymore and the Android ecosystem is
constantly evolving and Android now not
only runs on phones but things like
Chromebooks tablets Samsung our desktop
extension technologies like Samsung Dex
and coming very soon the world of
foldables so tons of OEMs are working on
foldable devices you might have heard of
the Samsung Galaxy fold so as game
developers you guys need to start
considering what kinds of devices that
your players are gonna be experiencing
your game on it could be a phone in
portrait mode it could be a Chromebook
or Dex device with a keyboard and mouse
attached or pretty soon it could be a
foldable with two screens that are
changing the resolutions when they open
up the device so maybe I want to get a
quick show of hands of how many of you
have actually thought about this problem
and maybe have a game that you've
optimized for a game or for a device
that's not just a mobile phone
stro hands okay not too many so that's
good hopefully you guys learn a lot
today then and this is really important
because as game developers write we want
to provide the best possible gaming
experience for our players no matter
what device they happen to be playing it
on so as gameplay continues to evolve
you know jit not only devices are
evolving but we're seeing the gameplay
evolve as well
so mobile gaming isn't just hyper casual
one-button OneTouch games anymore right
we're seeing these gameplay designs that
mirror something you'd expect on like a
PC or a console with longer playing
sessions more advanced controls and so
people like me and many others want to
play these types of games on Android in
a way that I would expect to play it
maybe at home on a console or on a PC
with a keyboard and mouse and not only
that but maybe I want to see it on a
bigger more beautiful screen I want to
avoid kind of a hand cloth playing my
favorite MMORPG for many hours on end
and it's not just about providing the
best possible experience it's also about
reach one of the key themes of the
gaming keynote this year at i/o which I
don't know if you guys saw it was about
reach and reaching more players and so
gamers the number one thing that we hear
from our end users are that they want to
play games on these devices and our
friends at Gameloft actually found this
out firsthand so they have a game
asphalt 8 and they saw that people were
playing it on a Chromebook and so they
went in and they we worked with them to
kind of optimize the controls and some
of the UI elements to suit these larger
screens and what they found is that
after they optimized it they saw a 6x
increase in daily active users and a 9x
increase in revenue just for the Chrome
OS version of the app not against mobile
so you know this just go it kind of goes
to show that players want to play these
games on these other devices and so it's
really important there is a desire to
play across all these different classes
of devices so let's kind of talk going
over overview of what each of these kind
of classes are so starting off with
Chromebooks so you might know
Chromebooks as laptops but the operating
system Chrome OS now runs on a minute
many different kinds of devices we've
got all-in-one desktop boxes you've got
detachable x'
you've got tablets now like the pixel
slate there's a variety of inputs
usually associated with Chrome OS but
the primary input devices are keyboard
and touchpad and as you know or may not
know Android runs inside of a
Tanner on Chrome on Chrome OS so the
full version of Android is running
inside there and to your game it's
essentially running on an Android device
it's just that it happens to be
connected to a larger display device and
maybe it has inputs attached so what we
found for a lot of developers is that
90% of their game is probably running on
a chrome Chrome OS device right now if
you go and download it and the last 10%
it's just really easy small tweaks to
make sure it's fully optimized for that
hardware and Chromebooks are growing so
we saw that reach 26 percent market
share last year and year-over-year the
market is growing 77% for Chromebooks
according to NPD so Google's put a lot
of effort into growing the Chromebook
and Chrome OS lion and gamers are
continuing to buy these devices and they
want to play games tablets tablets have
been around since Android Honeycomb a
long time and you now you've got a wide
variety of tablets everything from the
pixel slate which is more I would say
high-end to more affordable devices and
other premium tablets like the Galaxy
Tab s4 and tablets remain a huge portion
of kind of what we think of as this
mobile gaming space right so according
to NPD last year 19% of all active
mobile gamers were playing on an Android
tablet and that's across all mobile
platforms so as you can see there's a
large group of players there that are
active and want to play games
third desktop extension technologies so
more and more we're seeing mobile
devices like a lot of Samsung devices
come with technology that allows you to
connect it to a larger display to
connect things like a keyboard and mouse
and actually it is not just the Android
OS with you've got a full screen app but
it actually simulates a multi window
environment where your game window can
be resized and dragged around so it's
much more like a desktop experience than
what you would expect from Android on
the phone and I just had before coming
very soon our foldables so we've got
tons of OEMs that we know are working on
foldable devices and there's gonna be a
lot of interesting
use-cases with the smaller outer screen
opening up to the larger inner screen so
this is something you guys we have to
think about as well coming very soon now
I realized the words new platform are
kind of scary to a lot of game
developers and there's already a lot of
challenge right on supporting all the
device fragmentation on Android but what
I want to stress here is that this is
all still Android and by following the
Android best practices which I'll talk
about today you're gonna get a great
baseline experience across all these
different devices now there are
obviously more targeted things you can
do for specific devices and form factors
but today I'm just gonna focus on the
stuff in the middle there the best
practices they're gonna give you the
best overall compatibility no matter
which device your players are gonna be
playing on and you know you can do this
all with one apk and it's possible you
don't have to do multiple apks you don't
have to try to fit everything into one
apk and stay underneath some size limit
this is all possible with one apk and it
starts with kind of changing your
mindset you know I get it you're in
development there's features that cap
the ship deadlines they have to be hit
patches they have to be pushed and it's
very easy for developers to kind of
start thinking about devices you know
I've got to fix I've got to fix this bug
for these devices I've got to improve
performance for these devices but you
know as engineers we're kind of taught
to be adaptive and anticipate changes
and make sure we handle a wide variety
of scenarios so I realize in the
fast-paced of game development you know
it could be very hard to think about
that but for supporting all these
devices the key thing I want to stress
is to anticipate changes and be adaptive
and for example you know you might
change your assumptions that you're not
just playing on a small small screen
with a set resolution you could be
playing on a laptop or a larger display
screen with a much different aspect
ratio and resolution you might have a
touchscreen you might not you might have
a controller attached or keyboard and
mouse you might have accelerometer you
might have a gyro available for input
and you might be playing on something
from a low-end phone all the way up to a
gaming capable high performance
Chromebook for example so it's really
important to kind of get rid of the
mindset of you're just building one apk
for a certain set of device with a
certain set of assumptions and build an
apk that can adapt and change no matter
what environment it's running in so
luckily in Android if you're not aware
there's this concept of configuration
changes which is the method by which
Android tells your your game and your
activity about things that have changed
with the environment you're running in
and that you might care about and adapt
to so there's lots of different
configuration change events that are
getting thrown around in Android when
things happens for example if a keyboard
gets attached or detached if the
orientation of the screen changes or
maybe the screen size resolution changes
as well and so by default what's gonna
happen is the Android OS is sitting
there and it's listening for any of
these configuration changes and what it
does by default is it'll ask you to
maybe save your game State it'll give
you some method to kind of save custom
data it's gonna restart your activity
and then it's gonna restart it and give
you back the data that you've saved to
try to re intense and and go back to
where you're at however for a lot of
resource heavy applications and
especially games we do not recommend
that you let the Android OS do this for
you because in some cases you can get
lots of configuration change events even
across a couple of different frames so
for resource heavy games restarting the
activity and reallocating all your
resources is gonna slow down the system
it's gonna slow it on your game and it's
not going to give that seamless
experience that you want when players
are switching between different
configurations so there's another way in
which you can handle configuration
changes and that's through handling them
yourself in your code so in your
manifest you can simply declare all
these different configuration changes
that you want to handle yourself and
then in your activity it's going to
instead of restarting your activity it's
going to invoke on configuration changed
and it's going to give you the new
configuration that you're running in so
now you can do things like scale your UI
or your OpenGL content to match the new
resolution you can't argue your control
scheme to adapt to some
input device that was attached or
detached etc etc and so there's lots of
different configuration changes that you
can listen for but what I've done is
I've kind of boil it down into three key
areas that I you guys should be thinking
about and kind of looking at when it
comes to handling these different types
of configuration changes and they are
screen considerations input
considerations and kind of how to build
your apk and set it up in a way that
it's going to be very adaptable across
all these different devices now
different devices mean that there are
certain configuration changes that will
happen more often or may be more
important to handle and be aware of but
again for the greatest baseline
compatibility which is what we suggest
everybody goes for you're gonna have to
kind of look at all of them so that's a
quick overview on configuration changes
now let's kind of jump into what are
some of the things considerations you
have around dealing with screen
configuration changes while you're
building out your game so you've got a
game and on devices like Chromebooks and
Samsung decks by default your game is
gonna be launched in a windowed
environment so this means that you have
a game window it can be dynamically
resize to different aspect ratios and
resolutions and this is by default so
this is much different than what you'd
expect happening on a mobile device when
your game gets launched and now coming
soon on devices like foldables you've
actually got a much different aspect
ratio on the outer screen and when you
open up the player can open up the game
or the foldable at any point in time and
your resolution and aspect race you're
gonna change yet again so you guys have
to be set up to handle that now each one
of these cases as I said is going to
fire off a non configuration changed
event so again the key all comes back to
handle these configuration changes and
make sure that your game is set up to do
so so in this example I've set up that I
want to handle screen size and
orientation configuration changes so now
if somebody's playing my game and either
one of those events happens I'm gonna
get a callback to my aunt
configuration changed and now I can
scale my UI to matchin resolution I can
adjust my orientation I can adjust my
input areas because if your screen
resolution changes now your touch input
areas are gonna change as well so it's a
pretty powerful function to be able to
do whatever you need to do that suits
your game and how you've built it to be
able to handle all these different
things that might be happening at any
point during gameplay now if your game
is always intended to be run in
full-screen which for a lot of mobile
developers and Android developers they
expect this there is a way to lock your
game to full screen so in your manifest
you can just simply declare resizable
activity equals false and this will by
default launch your game in a
full-screen and it will not be resizable
at all however we don't recommend that
you do this
only as a last resort or if you're
trying to fix some bugs in the meantime
because what it does is it limits the
user experience on these windowed kind
of environments so for example now they
can't have like a chat application open
or YouTube or something like that and
actually on mobile devices as well it
prevents it from running in split split
view mode so as you'll see a little bit
later in the deck when I talk about
foldables this becomes even more of a
limitation for the user if you don't
allow your game to run or to be the
resizable orientation so you should be
thinking about the default orientation
of the device you're running on so on
phones it's portrait but many other
devices it's not its landscape and
actually a lot of these devices now
we're seeing our convertibles so a pixel
books and other Chromebooks are a great
example where they can switch from a
clamshell landscape orientation to now
portrait tablet mode so it's really
important to make sure that you if you
haven't already specify the sensor
orientations at your game supports and
so what this is gonna do is it's gonna
tell the OS what orientations your game
runs in and you won't get into weird
situations where
if somebody flips the device into a
different orientation your game flips
upside down or it gets into some weird
orientation change loop and if you're
handling it in code make sure using
displayed I get rotation as this is
gonna get you the actual rotation of the
device but be aware that the rotation
might be swapped the default values
depending on what the default hardware
orientation is so just be aware of that
now another thing with foldables to
think about now is aspect ratio becomes
really important so as you can see
they're on the outer screen the aspect
ratio is much longer it's 21 9 to be
exact and so for supporting full screen
on that outer screen you kind of have
three options just to make sure your
game is gonna handle this correctly the
first is the target SDK 26 and above
which for a lot of you if you're pushing
updates this is required by Google Play
Now so that's the first option make sure
you also set your resizable activity is
true so again letting the system resize
your application as it needs to be done
and now if neither of those are an
option for you what you have to do then
is specify a max aspect ratio inside
your manifest so this needs to be set
underneath the application tag 2.4 will
handle values up the earth will handle
aspect ratios up to 21 9 so that ensures
that your game will run on these kind of
different aspect ratios and of course
when you do this make sure that your UI
and everything behaves the way you would
expect it to on these different aspect
ratios now I talked a little bit about
split split view and unfold balls
there's this new feature in Android P
called multi resume so with these larger
screens there is this interesting use
case that now you can have multiple
activities up and running on the screen
at the same time now by default as of
Android P and earlier if you had two
activities running in split view mode
only the one that was last interactive
with is going to be running in the
onresume state everything else would
either be a non start or on paused which
doesn't make a lot of sense because then
you can't really
play a game or interact have a chat like
application update if you're not
interacting with it so now in key
there's this new feature called multi
resume which means that if both the OEM
and the game developer or application
developer opted in to this feature now
every top-level visible activity is
going to be in the on resume state so
essentially this means that users can
finally multitask on these larger
screens and they can have the game open
with a chat application or whatever so
this again is really important that your
to tie it back to make sure your game
does support use cases like this because
as more and more players pick up
foldable devices they're gonna expect it
something like this works it'll be a
disappointment to them if they download
your game and they find out they can't
utilize it now to support multi resume
it's super easy again you just go in
your manifest and you add this metadata
in there so now if both the OEM and you
have opted into multi resume your going
to support it and for devices that don't
yet support multi resume it'll run
exactly as it does by default where only
the last activity that the user
interacted with will be running in the
on resume state so it's really easy to
support it and if it does if the device
does not support it there's no risk
there for you now in general with more
pixels comes more flexibility as well
with HUD and UI design so if your
players are playing on a larger screen
consider what UI elements they can add
expand change or adapt to suit that
display so they also tend to sit farther
away from the screen the larger that
screen is so make sure all your text and
elements are readable and identifiable
as well and our friends over at Clay the
makers of don't starve did a great job
of handling this where they actually
give you the option of removing the
virtual joystick and the touch buttons
on the screen and you can also scale the
size of the UI and HUD to match what you
would expect or whatever device you
happen to be playing on so it's a great
example of giving users the choice of
setting up to
optimize for a certain screen size so
now let's talk about input and input I'm
gonna throw up this line again because
input is a very this is where this comes
into play because input is very volatile
at any point during your gameplay a user
can attach an input device they could
remove an input device and so it really
comes down to again trying to anticipate
that you're going to get some kind of
input Hardware event and being adaptive
to what that is
and by being adaptive that really means
try to anticipate what the user might
intend so obviously if somebody attaches
a controller in the middle of gameplay
they probably want to use that
controller so your game should just
naturally switch over to it and not only
doing that but allowing users to choose
what kind of input methods that they
want to use so you might find that
there's a bunch of different input
methods that are attached to the device
that your game is running on you want to
give players the choice of picking which
one so it all comes down again to it's
not just a touchscreen there could be a
lot of other things attached to it as
well that the users want to play with so
again ties back to the configuration
changes and so here in this example I'm
setting up that I want to handle
keyboard if being attached or detached
and also if the keyboard becomes
unusable so that's that keyboard hidden
flag right there and where that comes
into play is on things like pixel books
you might have a keyboard that's
available in the hardware when you're in
clamshell mode but once a user flips it
into the tablet the keyboards on the
back side and is no longer usable so
it's important to also not forget about
the keyboard hidden configuration events
as well and now a way to kind of
approach right this volatility of all
these different input methods what I've
kind of done here is as an example right
trying to detect maybe a game startup or
during my on configuration change loop
trying to detect all the devices that
are available for me to control the game
so I can use input manager here to kind
of loop through all the hardware
and figure out what input devices are
attached to this particular device and
then once I do that I can loop through
and kind of maybe check out and see is
there a mouse attached is there a
keyboard attached is the keyboard usable
and it comes down to kind trying to
assess the state of all the input
devices that are currently available and
then in this case you know if I detect
that I have a mouse and I have a
keyboard and it's usable I now switch my
control scheme over to desktop mode
right so I've got WASD and maybe mouse
to click or something like that so it
comes down to kind of trying to figure
out what's available to you and what the
user might want to use and this also
ties in with what is your game play
right so obviously for a first-person
shooter type the game play mouse control
is going to be more important if you've
got a third-person camera maybe use the
mouse to control that or using WASD to
control the player movement so adapt it
not only adapt it for your game as well
right different gameplay different
things are gonna make sense so asphalt 9
game lofts
did a great job of this with asphalt 9
and asphalt 8 we're basically at any
point during gameplay if somebody
attaches a new input device like a game
controller it just seamlessly pauses the
game it pops up a new dialog that shows
the user okay here's all the buttons you
need to press for a actual controller
and throughout the entire game they
change all of their text and kind of
visual textures to show that new input
method whatever the primary input method
is and on top of that they also let the
users go into the options at any point
in time and adjust what control method
they want to use so it's a great example
and I recommend you check it out again
being adaptive and anticipating those
changes and you know for a lot of you
that make mobile games you might not
think that keyboard support makes a lot
of sense for your type of game and I
would ask you maybe though to consider
that when you add in keyboard support
you improve the accessibility of your
game so you could do things like
skill keybindings WASD from character
movement menu navigation if you really
want to get fancy you could also let
players map specific buttons to in-game
actions so they can set it up to play
exactly how they want
don't forget about mouse capture so this
was added in Android Oh dis mouse
capture API and it's very very
frustrating when I boot up a
first-person shooter or something else
and I try to use the mouse and it does
not work so it's really easy to dis
request pointer capture it locks the
cursor of the center of the screen you
can get your motion vectors from your
mouse and then if you want at some point
you can release the pointer capture to
go back to standard Mouse control so it
really really makes a huge difference
and makes games infinitely more playable
when you're playing on something like a
pixel book in laptop mode if you can use
the mouse and it works game controllers
now game controllers have been around
for a long time on Android and there's
been game controller api's with varying
levels of game controller support from
the from developers so there's more and
more game controllers that are being
launched for Android and as we see kind
of these new devices that are running
Android there's a growing interest in
players being able to pick up some kind
of Bluetooth enabled controller sitting
on their couch and playing on a larger
display device so consider adding in
game controller support because it's
becoming more and more prevalent so
we've talked about screen considerations
and we've talked about input
considerations now I want to talk about
some general considerations around
building and setting up your apk in a
way to make sure it supports all these
various devices running Android so first
off you should review your permissions
that you're asking for and not only your
permissions but your features so not all
features are supported across all these
different devices and if you're blindly
asking for a certain feature that's not
available somebody's going to come along
in the Play Store excited to play your
game they're gonna try to download it
and it's gonna say this game is not
supported on
device which is not a win for anybody so
what I recommend you do is you list them
is not required in your manifest unless
you absolutely need them and then in
your code just check for the
availability at run time and if they're
not available just handle it gracefully
if you can so again being adaptive to
the device you're running on so good
examples of features that are not
supported on all these devices or things
like GPS by SMS even something like the
back facing camera is not present in a
lot of Chromebooks so if you ask for
these or need them for certain features
you won't be able to download on those
devices now you should also consider the
hardware profile that your game could be
running on right so I know a lot of game
developers either have some kind of
quality profiles set up for different
device classes or performance levels and
some developers actually implement you
know kind of runtime automatic quality
control detection system that's seeing
what your frame rate is and trying to
adjust things like draw counts and stuff
like that on the fly it's really
important to test to either test the
automatic quality control software you
might be running or to add quality
profiles set up for you know these new
range of devices right so if you've got
a gaming focused Chromebook that comes
out or something like that that has a
lot more you know CPU and GPU
performance potential try to create
profiles or make sure your game handles
a case of running on this higher-end
systems and looks great on these larger
screens
additionally try to provide an x86 build
if you can so a lot of Chrome OS devices
are Intel only and while your arm
binaries are still run you might incur
some overhead with the instruction
translation that's happening so try to
provide an x86 version of your native
libraries if you can I'm going to talk
about Android app bundles in a little
bit which is a great tool to make this a
lot easier to support rather than just
inside your apk along with your arm
value binaries
and if you're going for the most
graphical performance lots of these
devices now support Vulcan and Vulcan is
reached a point where it is we're seeing
lots of gains from developers that are
choosing to use it in terms of
maximizing their battery performance and
their graphical performance as well
so consider moving over to Vulcan if
you're really going to that high
fidelity type gameplay and finally test
across all these devices so ad test
cases that cover things like resizing
minimizing maximizing switching from the
smaller screen to the larger inner
screen I know that you might not have
all these devices or have the resources
available to have the actual physical
that devices the test on so use things
like the Android or Chrome OS emulator
to test on samsung has released a
foldable emulator that works on Android
studio as well so just try to boot up
your game and one of those if you don't
have the actual device and see how it
behaves and doing that you're gonna be
able to get a great idea of if you have
any major problems right out of the gate
also you can use something like firebase
test lab to help automate the process as
well which has all these different kinds
of devices inside of it and in the
spirit of you know using the tools that
are available for these different
devices Chrome OS specifically has a
performance tool they just announced
here at i/o that if you are looking at
developing for Chrome OS I highly
recommend you take a look at it as it
shows you it's kind of like systrace if
you use that where it shows you how the
desktop is being composited when the
memory swapping is occurring CPU GPU
frequencies and so on so highly
recommend you use the tools available
for the specific devices if they exist
and if there's a tool that you guys
would like to see that's not available
let us know somehow and we will do our
best to try to accommodate that now I
kind of mentioned Android app bundles
and for those of you you know to tie it
back to what I said about you can do
this with one apk
right well you can do with one apk or
you can do with one Android app bundle
and Android app bundles are essentially
a new way of distribution on the Google
Play Store where it saves you from
having to manage multiple apks or trying
to fit everything inside of a single apk
and staying underneath the Play Store
size requirements for your base apk so
instead of uploading an apk to Google
Play what you do is you put everything
all your native libraries all your
different screen density resolution
assets all your localization files into
an app bundle and you upload that to
Google Play and now what Google Play is
gonna do is when somebody comes along on
let's say high resolution x86 device
it's gonna generate and sign and give
them an optimized apk that only contains
the x86 and high-resolution assets so
they get a smaller download size and
they don't get all this extra stuff that
they don't need to run the game now some
of you might be aware of on the Play
Store that there's a hundred megabyte
limit for your apk if you go over that
amount you have to use expansion files
if you use app bundles that limit is
actually increased to 150 megabytes so
we're really recommending like this is
what we feel is the future of
distribution on the Play Store and
Android in general so we've been
recommending to all developers and
especially game developers that have a
lot of assets and different sets of
libraries we recommend you guys try to
switch over to app bundles if you can as
quickly as possible and luckily it's
pretty easy to do I've talked about that
if using unity 20 18.3 and above you can
simply just choose to build an app
bundle instead of an apk or if you're
using Android studio 3.2 and above you
can simply again choose to build an app
bundle instead of an apk and then once
you build that app bundle you just
upload it straight to the Google Play
Store now if you have a custom build
pipeline or something like that you can
use a great tool called bundle tool to
generate an app bundle from the command
line
and another useful feature a bundle tool
is that not only will it generate an app
bundle for you to use it'll also let you
generate tests apks from that app bundle
so let's say you build your app bundle
and now you can generate specific apks
for different device configurations and
hand that off to your QA team or to your
automated testing solution such that you
know you get all the benefits of this
app bundle smaller download size sizes
but you don't have any of the overhead
of trying to also generate apks to fit
into your existing testing processes so
it's a great tool and I recommend you
guys check it out okay so talked about a
lot different things today and obviously
there's a lot more we could talk about
but what I really want to stress to you
guys again is that Android gaming is not
just phones anymore
players are experiencing whether you
know about it or not or like it or not
they are experiencing your game across a
wide variety of devices and by following
some of these best practices that I've
talked about so thinking about the
screen input setting up your apk in a
smart way you're going to cover all
these additional use cases and get the
best possible gaming experience for your
players no matter what device they
happen to be playing on and if there's
one thing that you take away you know we
talked a lot about a lot about different
technical points I want to stress in it
if you start off just by changing your
mindset about what you're what kind of
device you're building for in the sense
that you're not making any assumptions
about its capabilities or what input
devices or input methods it might have
attached to it just change your mindset
and try to build something that's
adaptive as possible either in your next
game engine or your next game that
you're a patek building and if you start
off just by spending a little bit of
time thinking about these additional use
cases it's gonna make your life a lot
easier and you're already gonna get you
know 99% of the way there so I want to
call out if you're very interested in
maybe having your game looked at and
seeing how it might function on these
different devices
or any other technical questions you
might have we're actually doing game
reviews in the garage back there so
highly recommend you guys stop by and
check it out you can just go through the
doors over there in the back corner
there's a walk-up desk either myself or
one of my esteemed colleagues can sit
down and talk with you guys about any
kind of technical issues you might be
having and that's it I hope you guys
found this talk informational and
exciting and I hope a lot more of you
consider all these different devices
when you as you continue to build out
your games and thank you so much and I
hope you have a great rest of the i/o
Thanks
[Music]
you